Guten morgen tim.
Also weil streamen und fällt mir immer diese blöde nazareth ohrwurm aus den achtzigern dream und.
Wenn du weißt auf was dream on auf deutsch heißt ne.
Ja ja träume weit.
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundert und zehn frisch eingesprochen am neunten august zweitausendneunzehn,
von uns euren podcast an um die ecke von nebenan eure podcaster von nebenan.
Ja
sitzen wir hier wieder genau wir haben etwas zusammengefasst ganz einfach in diesem sommerloch überhaupt noch irgendwas aufregend würdiges zu finden allerdings ist auch mit positive meldungen immernoch dünne.
Einmal in eine haben wir ja.
Eine okay das reicht ja also die die die muss quote jetzt.
Wollen wir schon mal ankündigen dass wir beim camp die ehre haben werden oder oder sagen wir das jetzt lieber noch gar nicht.
Das hat gut funktioniert wenn wir das noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Wir laufen ne beim camp haben wir glaube ich noch nicht gesagt das haben die.
Ist ja egal können wir ja trotzdem machen.
Wir beim fc camp am donnerstag das ist der tag zwei der zweiundzwanzigste,
achte so,
die zweiundzwanzig uhr fuffzehn rum plus minus werden wir dann eine livesendung im monkey village machen dürfen.
Genau nehmen wir natürlich auch auf gar keine frage und gibt's dann auch für die nicht teilnehmer auf die ohren aber wenn ihr da ohnehin seid.
So ihr denn ein ticket bekommen hab dann würden wir uns natürlich freuen wenn ihr auch vorbeikommen würdet und dann sicherlich zeit auch die eine oder andere hand zu schütteln ne.
Ja da also danach ne während der sendung ja nicht so aber danach das hätte es wird sicherlich ganz wieder eine sehr verehrte verschoben sind noch.
Aber dieser letztes camp waren wir auf der bühne ich bin,
froh dass das war nämlich habe ich dann wurde ich neidisch weil ihr nämlich dann am bei der freak show wart ihr auf der ber bühne das ist ja quasi große teile des teams die jetzt auch,
tim machen.
Ist auch in derselben ecke.
Und am samstag macht ihr nämlich deine frühshoppen.
Richtig genau.
Also donnerstag logbuch schlechte laune samstag gute laune und nach der show gibts auch noch ein bisschen musik von rosa luxus und besen.
Wir können ja überlegen nur positive nachrichten zu diskutieren.
Nur positive nachricht eine positive nachricht habe ich noch ich habe noch eine positive.
Für jetzt schon verbrennt ihr dann alles aber nichts mehr auf dem camp.
Am dreiundzwanzigsten freitag der dreiundzwanzigste achte um dreiundzwanzig uhr beim camp gibt's musik.
In der in der lounge.
Das ist auch einer wesen und rosa luxus am start ja und als vorband von dana ruh das ist eine sehr bekannte,
dj also man sieht auch hier ne die karriere also meine macht fortschritte.
So was hast du damit.
Ich bin da auch mit äh am auflegen ich hab die ich sorge dafür dass wir die kicks kriegen sein.
Ton assi.
Ne ich hab beim ich habe da auch beim beim kongress richtig aufgeregt.
Du darfst zwischendurch das zwischendurch auch mal.
Ich darf mir ab und zu was wünschen.
Anne und ich treffe uns dann auch heute zur vorbereitung des sets das wird er da geht ja von meiner seite denn muss da auch sehr viel vorbereitungszeit reingehen.
So viel zu tun na gut.
Also donnerstag logbuch freitag joker musik samstag frische und schenkel musik was kann da schon schief gehen und ich sagte ich will das nur dich jetzt hier ankündigen weil ich nicht weiß ob wir überhaupt nochmal vom camp eine sendung machen.
Dann lass mal feedback machen.
Ja also es gab sehr viel feedback zu der sendung und ich habe gerade überlegt ob ich das nochmal zusammenfassen aber ehrlich gesagt einfach es gab eine längere diskussion mit mehreren diskussionen teilnehmer zum thema enterprise security micha,
am rande eigentlich nur erwähnt hatte das unternehmen sowas gerne machen also dass sie quasi auch männer in der mittel position maschinen in der mitte position eingehen zwischen ihren mitarbeitern,
dem internet
mit dem ziel dort festzustellen oder sicherzustellen dass irgendwie nichts böses passiert also keine infektion stattfinden kann kommen control traffic ganz eine längere diskussion zu empfiehlt sich
zu lesen würde ich jetzt aber nicht nochmal hier.
Ausführlich zusammenfassen weil ich auch gleichzeitig wieder mails bekommen habe wo drin stand das mir alles viel zu kompliziert kannst du es nochmal erklären und ich dachte eigentlich hätten das ganz gut erklärt mit die,
mit die zertifikate.
Wir auch kompliziert.
Kompliziert und zdf.
Dann haben wir die gute nachricht des tages die gute nachricht des tages hab ich tatsächlich heute als sms auch schon bekommen.
Diesmal vor.
Ja vertrags information lieber kunde ab sofort werden videos
in der stream option musik musik music and video
in der maximal vom jeweiligen anbieter des videos framing angeboten übertragung qualität übertragen die bandbreiten optimierung für videos auf eins komma sieben mbit wurde deaktiviert im übrigen bleibt ihre option
unverändert informationen telekom de stream und ihre telekom was ist geschehen.
Ein großer telekom konzern schenkt dir was und vor allem vorwegnehmen ist ja nicht das einzige geschenk dabei wird es nicht bleiben,
ende des monats gibt's dann auch noch all das was man bisher nur in deutschland auf diese art und weise kostenlos konsumieren durfte auch in der ganzen
eu da fragt man sich wie kann es denn zu einem solchen wandel kommen.
Na wir haben es ja vor.
Die mainz nur gut mit uns oder.
Die mainz völlig gut mit uns sie haben sich nur einfach ne wie das so ist wie leute die sich gut meinen die krallen sicherheit mit den fingernägeln am tisch fest und strampeln müssen dann halt irgendwie zu ihrem glück gezwungen werden,
das ganze weil hier eine längere rechtliche auseinandersetzungen zwischen usa und deutscher telekom an deren anfang,
schon immer stand das das was sie da machen nämlich einerseits bandbreiten drosselten,
und zweitens die beschränkung dieser sirup dieses rating angebotes auf das,
der deutsche heimat netz sodass es die stream one option im e u ausland eben nicht.
Möglich ist oder nicht angeboten wird obwohl wir ja damals mit einem der gleichen.
Regulation bekommen haben einerseits die ähm.
Die regulatorischen zur netz neutralität und gleichzeitig soweit ich das erinnere auch die regeln zum eu-rat wo die
quasi vereinheitlicht wurden die preise und auch quasi erzwungen wurde dass es innerhalb der eu keine roaming zuschläge mehr,
geben darf und damit dagegen bis sicher jetzt diese deutsche telekom die jetzt quasi roaming für
daten bestimmte daten freigabe im eu ausland erhob indem sie nämlich sagte pass auf wenn du ein video das gleiche video in,
polen cox kostet das geld wenn es in deutschland macht's nicht und das wäre im prinzip dann ein verstoß gegen dieses ding wir hatten das vor ein paar sendung auch besprochen dass dann eben letztendlich die usa.
Recht bekommen hat mit beiden aspekten die drosselten muss weg das ist das was jetzt passiert ist zweitens die limitationen auf europa muss weg und
die frage die sich eben stellte ist wie reagiert nun die deutsche telekom wird sie sagen okay viel beschnitten jetzt stream.
Wir nehmen die option weg was eventuell sekunden gekostet hätte oder kunden auch ein sonderkündigungsrecht eingeräumt hätte,
oder sagt sie na gut wir machen stream on wir machen sie rating aber wenn man es dann eben auch europaweit und ohne drosselten.
Und das ist doch schön das ist doch schön ja kann man sagen danke benefits a und danke vor allem thomas der ja seit jahren für das regulatorisches framework auf eu-ebene dafür gekämpft hat und.
Beziehungsweise danke an works also alle die da mithelfen dass es natürlich nicht allein thomas werk beziehungsweise das was er,
hat konkret tun können das kriegt man auch nochmal hin wenn viele andere mithelfen und ja da war einfach diese gruppe ganz weit vorne und
bin gespannt wann wir die nächsten auswirkungen haben weil es gibt ja noch diverse andere tarife wenn jetzt hier so ein
angemietet tarif kaufst dann gilt er ja auch erstmal nur in deutschland und in der eu halt entsprechend limitiert ich würde das gerne sehen wenn das dann auch mal fällt.
Also müssen sozusagen ist in diesem eu roaming ist ja auch festgelegt was der quasi der einheit bei preis ist im roaming,
wie er verrechnet wird und da gibt es eben roaming haben wir hier öfter auch schon besprochen es gibt da,
problematiken wie jetzt beispielsweise du musst auf einer eigentlich relativ verlassenen insel ein riesiges spanisches.
Mobilfunknetz bauen damit die ganzen deutschen asis da irgendwie netz bekommen was.
Wozu eben die einnahmen aus dem roaming überschüssen,
wenn es das so gibt genutzt werden können oder behauptet werden genutzt zu werden alles nicht so einfach weil die telekom muss beim,
muss schon wenn jetzt die leute roman das auch bezahlen allerdings,
glaub ich ist ganz klar thomas hat das von anfang an gesagt und,
ich habe ihnen auch gefragt ob er irgendwie gelegenheit hat in diese sendung zu kommen das war nicht so ohne weiteres möglich aber sein
kommentar dazu war ungefähr so hast du gesagt hab ich doch gesagt hab ich doch gesagt so ungefähr könnt ihr euch thomas vorstellen,
und da kann man eigentlich nur sagen ja hat er gesagt hat er recht ja,
war jetzt auch nicht so schwer erstaunlich dass die dass die deutsche telekom sich da,
also die haben glaube ich da sehr sehr vertrauen gehabt in in was auch immer außerhalb dieser regeln und gesetze und der auflagen steht.
Dass sie mit der nummer durchkommen mal schauen wie sie es jetzt langfristig an anpassen,
das wäre jetzt wirklich mal so ein beispiel dass der dass die forderung auch wirklich sollte ja immer so wer sich
ein stream gefragt heran getraut hat wie jetzt hier thomas weil dann sofort wurde als dann der der feind der kunden gebrannt mag ne die wollen auch die schöne option wieder wegnehmen stellt sich raus
das wofür das jetzt hier wozu das jetzt hier geführt hat ist 'ne signifikante verbesserung der leistung für die für die kundinnen und kunden.
Absolut ich meine man kann natürlich auch.
Jetzt argumentieren dass die telekom das im prinzip hat vielleicht auch kommen sehen dass sie aber es ist halt erstmal so probiert haben und das ganze schlicht als marketing tool für jakob mal zu uns da gibt's richtig daten
genutzt hat und das halt einfach mit ihrem großen netz und mit ihren sicherlich irgendwo auch gut ausgehandelte,
gegenseitigen verrechnen von roman kosten als er ist nicht so dass jetzt nur die telekom.
Kosten im ausland für sich erzeugt sein genauso ist es natürlich mit anderen leuten die durch deutschland cruisen und es wird dann am ende erstmal alles gegen gerechnet nur die differenz wird dann,
finanziell ausgeglichen und ich kenne natürlich diese,
wieder anfallen aber ich glaube das ist alles irgendwie eingepreist und jetzt haben sie sich halt viele millionen kunden irgendwie eingetreten über dieses feature die bleiben jetzt auch erstmal und die kosten können sie tragen also das hatten wir ja auch am anfang an,
schon die erkenntnis dass eigentlich dieses angebot an sich diese ganze diskussion mit es gibt nicht genug bandbreite,
völlig absurd führt weil offensichtlich geht ja dann doch auf einmal,
und man kann sich eigentlich nur fragen warum kriegt man nicht einfach mehr daten.
Für ordentlichen preis alles machbar ist alles nur verteidigung.
Mehr daten für weniger geld.
Nicht so schöne nachrichten gibt's aus den usa hat mir auch schon ein paar mal,
erwähnt chelsea meeting ist ja.
Einst mal begnadete worden wurde aber jetzt von der amerikanischen justiz wieder mal in beuger haft genommen worden kam dann wieder frei um dann kurz danach wieder einen burger
genommen zu werden jetzt ist das ganze aber auch noch mit tagessätzen strafe belegt,
konkret sie das jetzt so aus dass jeden tag den sie nicht bereit ist,
gegen julian massage auszusagen was sie halt da ablehnt mit einer strafe von eintausend,
pro tag belegt wird es gab auch schon vorher eine strafe die lag bei fünfhundert
dollar und das hat sich jetzt irgendwie erhöht auf eintausend dollar und dieser ganze spaß kann bis zur ende einer also es gibt eine maximale zeit der beuger haft bei vierhundert tagen.
So dass dieses ganze paket sich auf irgendwas vierhundertfünfzigtausend us-dollar zusammentragen kann nebst freiheitsentzug.
Darauf läuft's aus anhörung wurden irgendwie dann auch noch verweigert nach dem motto ist ja eh keine kohle wohnungen schon verloren in diesem zusammenhang also das auf jeden fall ein,
erheblich,
einschränkung der freiheit gar keine frage vor allem wenn man im nasses und das generell nicht schön aber in den usa schon mal überhaupt nicht.
Das ist so der stand der dinge was sehen wir da also die justiz in den usa versucht halt alles irgendeiner form,
gegen julian zusammenzubekommen irgendwie auch so ein bisschen.
Strenge finde was auf der einen seite einen präsidenten haben mit seinem ganzen mafia regierungsstil team die glaube ich dieses thema ganz gerne vom tisch hätten.
Andererseits ist aber halt immer noch eine weitgehend unabhängige justiz gibt die,
aus welchen gründen auch immer hier diese sache vor vorantreiben wir jetzt erstmal so zu kinder.
Es gibt noch ein bisschen also wohin sie da genau aussagen soll das wäre jetzt nicht irgendein gerichtsverfahren sondern diese
jury was etwas ist dass es in deutschland nach meiner kenntnis so nicht,
gibt nämlich eigentlich ein geheimes gericht das,
sehr,
uneingeschränkte sabina kräfte hat also die was sie quasi an beweismittel beschlagnahmen oder erzwingen können daher auch genau das was jetzt gerade mit schätzchen mining machen und die,
aussage die man vor so einer grand tory hat ist auch wieder geheim und dadurch können die kann die jury,
quasi auch den eindruck erwecken dass einzelne die dort ausgesagt haben vielleicht mit dem mit den ermittlern,
zusammenarbeiten na das heißt also da die,
erzwingen quasi durch ihr vorgehen so ein bisschen hat sie dieses business dilemma immer mit drin und das hilft natürlich
ungemein in in einem gerichtsverfahren weshalb das glaube ich nach meiner kenntnis auch genau in gerichtsverfahren nicht gibt das business dilemma ist ja eigentlich nur eine situation der wo du noch,
gefangen bist bei der polizei und im gerichtsverfahren die müssen ja richtig müssen ja.
So die idee öffentlich die beweisaufnahme führen damit eben auch alle die dort sind wissen gegen welche vorwürfe sich verteidigen müssen und diese situation ist eben bei den vor einer grenze wieso nicht gegeben für dass es hier jetzt auch,
eine sehr klare politische oder eine sehr klare inhaltliche motivation gibt sich diesem verfahren nicht zu stellen darüber hinaus ob sie jetzt vielleicht schon,
schützen wollen würde oder nicht dass er sagt nein ich kritisiere überhaupt das grundsätzliche.
Verfahren dass hier stattfindet es gibt eine möglichkeit da finanziell zu unterstützen von action network werden wir da die fans fand quasi geführt haben wir in den,
schauen wir uns mal verlinkt.
Ja dann gab's wieder nazi kram.
Nazi schießereien zwei stück.
Was kann wann beide gleich gelagert das war nochmal so leicht hintergründe oder.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich hab die hintergrund jetzt gar nicht so parat wandere dritter und vierte august in passau und in daten.
Texas und in,
halt das übliche ding amerikaner dreht durch erschießt leute das gibt's da ja im prinzip täglich nur gibt es halt nicht täglich unbedingt immer in zweistelligen zahlen von,
erschossen diesmal war 's mal wieder sehr viel ich glaub,
und es ging halt irgendwie nach shopping mal wo halt wirklich viele einkaufen und der täter.
Ist ganz klar,
mal glaube ich mal jetzt nochmal so festhalten einfach motiviert durch die rhetorik und das generelle vorgehen und decken dieser ganzen weißen,
crowd von.
Präsidenten donald trump angefeuert worden benutzt dieselbe rhetorik in in seinem statement was er da veröffentlicht hat und so macht,
alle äh nach hause schicken wir müssen sie alle.
Am worden weil sie ja uns ersetzen würden also diese typische nazi rhetorik.
Die sicher normalerweise gegen juden werden das bei diesen demonstrationen in charles will auch schon gehabt wo er dann einer durchgedreht ist mit dem auto noch leute überfahren hat auch eine frau ums leben,
und die finale vorher alle rum und dann,
going to the place also dieses diese volks ersetzen die halt derzeit bei nazis ebenso der die,
sprach- methode ist im prinzip einfach rassistisch gegen andere gruppen vorzugehen.
Warum erwähnen wir das jetzt hier überhaupt wollen gar nicht so sehr über diese shootings reden sollen so ein bisschen darüber was,
dahinter so im digitalen so abspielt weil der ganzen berichterstattung wurde natürlich auch immer mal wieder darauf hingewiesen wo sich denn diese leute radikalisieren und es ist natürlich im internet.
Quatsch ist also radikalisieren sich nicht im eigentlichen sinne im internet sein sie kommen halt im internet in foren zusammen,
wo die anderen teil radikalisierte auch schon rumhängen und eine neue.
So neue aber eine webseite die hier immer wieder erwähnt wird ist eine acht,
und,
wollte mal kurz so mal aufgreifen worum es sich denn dabei eigentlich handelt ich hatte hier vor einiger zeit,
mal einen ich finde sehr schön gemacht über internet nehme.
Den wenn ihr noch nicht gehört habt ich sehr empfehlen kann weil er,
erstmal sehr sehr sehr viel da ist schon ein paar jahre her jetzt alles aber die ganzen klassiker oder viele viele der der klassiker die media selbst überhaupt erst so richtig bekannt gemacht haben.
Werden da erläutert und ihr zustande kommen und tatsächlich ist es so dass diese ganze medienkultur enorm durch eine beziehungsweise zwei websites befördert worden,
die erste webseite die eine rolle spielt ist eine japanische jetzt muss ich,
ein bisschen nachdenken bin ich ganz sicher aber wie es richtig erinnere gibt's eine japanische webseite die dieses prinzip des sogenannten image sports gestartet hat,
die hieß irgendwie,
kanal und.
Diese idee des sports wo man halt einfach im wesentlichen,
dem dann noch text anhängen so ein bisschen wie instagram in gewisser hinsicht fällt mir gerade ein,
das wurde dann von zum amerikaner nach programmiert und unter dem namen fortschein bekannt,
fortschein wiederum war dann eben wirklich so der durchlauferhitzer für medienkultur weil quasi dieses prinzip des sports war man postet ein bild.
Aber nach ein paar tagen sind alle werden alle posts automatisch wieder gelöscht das heißt die methode über die ein bild.
Kulturelle und damit magnetische kraft entwickelt kann,
das eben nur dadurch erreichen dass leute bilder immer wieder die schon gepostet wurden nehmen und immer wieder neu posten und dabei halt entweder unverändert oder dann eben ergänzt und verändert wieder posten,
was dann wiederum neue varianten hervorbringt und das ganze so ein evolutionäre charakter.
Innerhalb von fortschein gab's dann aber auch,
in den letzten jahren zu beobachten dass sich hier auch 'ne ganze menge,
rechts lästige leute organisiert haben und entsprechendes bildmaterial hier produziert haben dass man normalerweise nicht so gerne sieht.
Es muss noch kurz eine wichtige eigenart dieser image boards benannt werden.
Alle sind anonym.
Dieses spezifischen zumindest dieses spezifischen fortschein,
es gibt ja nicht so etwas wie nutzer account weil du gerade erst kurz mit mit instagram oder so verglichen hast es gibt keinen nutzer account es gibt keine anmeldung,
es gibt einfach ein feld wer trag deinen namen ein,
und du musst ein bild hochladen und ein text kann man auch noch dazu schreiben das ist das interface und die dinger werden
ähm genau wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere als treats,
gezeigt das heißt wenn auf ein bild geantwortet wurde dann geht das wieder nach oben.
Glaube ich zumindest zumindest wandert so oder so alles nach unten dann irgendwann durch und dann ist es für immer weg,
das ist,
klingt auf anhieb jetzt erstmal ein bisschen komisch hat aber eben bestimmte spiel dynamiken die da eben sehr.
Sehr interessant werden der typ der das der fortschein gemacht hat heißt übrigens mut christopher pool inzwischen ist er glaube ich bei google.
Aber der hat wenn ich das halbwegs richtig innere,
weil er auch irgendwann ganz vorsichtig von diesem fortschein mal,
distanzieren zu können zwanzig fünfzehn oder sollte.
Weil er weil er natürlich da auch so ein bisschen die folge hält war und hat sich irgendwie hat von vielen leuten feiern lassen müssen von den man vielleicht nicht unbedingt gefeiert werden möchte.
Dann noch ein anderer punkt ein wichtiges tipp mit in dem feld wo man seinen namen eintragen kann wenn man das möchte.
Gibt's ein die volt wert und der ist enorm und das war der ist der grund oder der der so zurückgehenden ursprung warum enormes.
Gruppe.
Diese gruppe internet aktivistinnen die jetzt irgendwie in letzter zeit,
um die stille geworden ist aber die immer noch halten.
Mein charakter hat da da ist dieser namens ursprung es gab dann auch mal irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht,
das noch gibt einen deutschen klonen,
kraut sichern.
Deutschland ist irgendwie weg punkt net da war der standard name wie man sich angesprochen hat bernd und wer sich ein bisschen in der mimik bewegt kennt,
die regelmäßige ansprache seiner selbst oder andere als bernd genauso.
Zum beispiel bernd höcke.
Ja der ist auch klar wo der her kam ne.
Ja aber wie schon erwähnt diese fortschein damit die am anfang noch ganz lustig war weil sie halt erstmal viele lustige lebens gebracht hat die über die wir alle herzlich lachen konnten katzenbär bilder etcetera also quasi das was man heute als,
images kennt das dass es eben originär aus dieser einen einzigen webseite hervorgegangen
aber umso mehr leute da sich,
getummelt haben umso mehr kam halt auch so ein bisschen so der dunkle aspekt des ganzen zum vorschein erstmal
kann man glaube ich auch sagen war das eben auch ein wunderbares troll forum ne weil.
Was hier auch.
Na ja oder es war das.
Also es war so ein troll erzeuger in gewisser hinsicht auch das heißt das kollektive einbrechen,
man hat da relativ schnell erkannt dass das irgendwie sehr effizient ist und während es halt am anfang von anonym muss noch dazu genutzt wurde um halt hier diese ganzen proteste auf die straße zu bringen um gegen,
hier.
Gegen sein tolle und so weiter vorzugehen ja wo man ja am anfang noch einen sehr positiven eindruck hatte und viele leute
ich glaube ich dieses ganze anonym usp hinnehmen halt unterstützt haben da gabs auch viel näher an den piraten und so weiter weil das ja sozusagen wir das internet wir sind anonym muss wir sind total cool wir sind zwar alle nur flüchtlinge fünfzehnjährige jugendliche aber wir können jetzt,
ändern aber wir haben eine maske und wir können irgendwie für für gutes wirken
kippte dann aber irgendwann um weil er einfach diese troll dynamiken dann den zunehmenden maße sich radikalisiert haben und eben auch benutzt wurden umso
konzentiert gegen leute vorzugehen die naja nicht ins eigene weltbild passen und das hat sich halt,
was da noch was.
Ich finde das ich find das ganz spannend weil also dadurch dass diese dass die,
diese boards dir die durch diese standard anonymität den und beziehungsweise jede,
dadurch dass jeder post jeden nutzer namen nehmen kann.
Lohnt es sich auch nicht es ist dir quasi auch unmöglich dort irgendwie fame aufzubauen als irgendjemand besonderes weil du kannst den namen eben nicht kleben du kannst natürlich anfangen und sagen ich poste jetzt hier als
was weiß ich bernd dreiundzwanzig und versuche mich irgendwie zu
zu profilieren kann jeder andere auch ja das heißt wenn du jetzt irgendwie anfängst dort.
Irgendwie eine identität oder eine individualität aufzubauen,
kann die jederzeit wieder zunichte gemacht werden wo wodurch das ganze ding so 'ne kollektivität hat und,
du eben da nur er merkt merkst ach hey der hat ja jetzt gar nicht jedes ich oder du oder er durch bernd ersetzt nu ja und das heißt die du
das ganze ding lebt dann auch und der baut auf so ein so eine ganz stark kulturelles gefühl dann auf wieso wir ne und du weißt hört nicht wie viele
andere hunde dann noch sitzen und und mitmachen wie viele bernds es überhaupt gibt.
Und die frage ist halt ne was was ist denn dann dieses bier gefühl und aus diesem wir bekämpft jetzt mal sein tolles und weil diese scheiße und das wird der auslöser war ja im prinzip auch so ah die wollten jetzt hier unser.
Video verfolgen die dieses tolles tolles video was da gepostet wurde im netz dem sitze hinterher gegangen und dann war wir halt das internet ne also anonym muss hat sich am anfang ein bisschen außer als,
das internet verteidigt sich jetzt wir sind stark und irgendwann hat natürlich das als identität klammer so nicht mehr gereicht,
und hat sich dann eben in andere bereiche,
auf andere bereiche reduziert da kann man sich fragen okay was ist denn dann noch die gemeinsamkeit wenn wir uns nicht alt das internet fühlen sondern es ist halt irgendwie vor allem natürlich jungs die da unterwegs sind die sich im internet bewegen und dann,
kam die konflikte auf und es hat sich dann das erste mal so richtig krass entladen finde ich mit dieser ganzen gamer geht debatte ja die alles war als,
das was der name sagt im wesentlichen war gamer geht einfach ein,
antifa feministische frauenfeindliche troll bewegung im netz,
unter dem vorgeschobenen argument man würde jetzt irgendeine diskussion über qualität über journalismus im gaming.
Es gab ja dann,
frauenfeindliche verhalten von gaming companies beziehungsweise eben auch,
problematische männer bild überhaupt in der ganzen gamma kultur probleme also beides problematisch es frauenbild und problematisch es männer bild in dieser ganzen games szene angeprangert wurde,
das hat dann eben wieder viele aufgeregt in diesen foren so nach dem motto,
ihr wollt jetzt uns angreifen ja uns es in männer im internet und dann wurde halt in fortschein dieselbe.
Methodik angewendet,
wie vorher eben gegen sein tolles man hat halt da sozusagen sich in der masse organisiert und ist dann eben kollektiv auf twitter und anderen wegen mit boxing und was nicht allen
gegen einzelne personen vor allem halt frauen vorgegangen oder eben auch gegen männer die sich da,
schützend an die seite der frauen gestellt haben ich kann mich noch erinnern als das irgendwie heiß war da hat mir,
auch so ein paar kommentare von leuten die man so ja nie aber jetzt alle wort quality in journalisten und so,
kann man einfach mal sagen die sorry also gamer geht kann geht jetzt eigentlich primär als sündenfall in die internet geschichte ein denn das hat einfach mal gezeigt,
wie problematisch diese ganze troll kultur mittlerweile geworden ist in der folge hat ja dann twitter auch angefangen,
langsam langsam langsam und heute immer noch nicht schnell genug und andere netze auch,
entsprechende technische maßnahmen zu ergreifen so eier accounts und,
schnell eröffnete accounts die gleich voll nutzen haben und so weiter das alles in irgendeiner form bisschen einzuschränken aber es ist halt auch so ein bisschen kannst und maus und so richtig abgestellt hat das internet diesen faktor noch nicht.
Jetzt sind wir so in der aktuellen zeit und haben vielfache auswirkungen davon gespürt jetzt gibt es also nochmal eine verdoppelung,
beziehungsweise ganz konkret haben wir gerade schaut gibt's schon gerade nicht mehr aber es gab zumindest vielleicht gibt es auch bald wieder habe ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher dass das nicht weg ist ist dann,
grob gesagt so ein bisschen die auskopplung all der ganzen leute auf fortschein dient einfach sowieso nur noch um,
rechtsgerichteten troll scheiß ging und es halt so 'n tunnel forum für für nazis und andere zerstörte und er ist im prinzip so das mit sport was eben die schlechtesten seiten von fortschein,
dann soweit institutionalisierte hat dass es eben mittlerweile so der ort ist wo diese ganzen weißen nationalisten die irgendwie ihre terroranschläge planen dann sozusagen ihre manifeste veröffentlichen und sich,
vielleicht eben darüber auch einfach an sich weiter radikalisieren.
Dieser attentäter hatte glaube ich sogar irgendwie so eine äußerungen getätigt wiedersehen dem
anderthalb jahren die ihr jetzt auf mehr gelernt hätte als je zuvor also der spezifisch auch in bezug nochmal hergestellt dass er irgendwie
die,
die die wahrheitsgemäß habe war aus der er sich genähert hat und dieser paar so attentäter hat eben auch jetzt wieder ein manifest mehrere tausend
wörter glaube ich auf.
Auf veröffentlicht und jetzt gibt's die diskussion musste.
Beziehungsweise welche infrastruktur trägt überhaupt und da gibt es natürlich den eigentlichen server aber es gibt vor allem auch was heutzutage ja sehr wichtig ist für solche umstrittenen seits,
den schutz vor bösen detox attacken der heutzutage werde weniger bei dir voll von der firma cloud flair übernommen wird also
bei die volt aber das ist auch mal mit abstand der größte netzwerk infrastruktur schutz provider und cloud fährt ja neulich schon.
Einen kunden gehen lassen was war das nochmal.
Ah ich krieg gerade nicht zusammen es gab doch schon da gab's auch schon eine andere das war jetzt der daily store dieses.
Woher diese.
Nazi forum halt auch und auch über cloud leer und die,
führungsetage von cloud flair.
Zumindest so viel standing dass sie halt sagen naja das,
spricht hier mal nicht unseren prinzipien und wofür wir stehen und,
machen wir keine dienstleistungen für und haben die dann irgendwie ziehen lassen der die firma und später noch entscheiden dann irgendwie bei einer anderen bruder untergekommen die.
Weißt du immer so ganz genau ich hab so in erinnerung dass irgendwie ein russische
russische service war also die sind dann sozusagen nicht automatisch vom netz gegangen obwohl jetzt gerade so nicht verfügbar ist wir wollen uns eigentlich nochmal ein bisschen motivation holen und nochmal ein bisschen radikalisiert aus,
nicht funktioniert.
Ja die frage ist natürlich dann wieder.
Wenn jetzt also ein privatunternehmen effektiv entscheiden kann werden können diese seite offline nehmen oder nicht dann mag das irgendwie mittelfristig irgendwie ganz angenehm sein oder schön sein für diesen für diesen augenblick aber
eigentlich willst du das halt nicht dass solche entscheidungen letztendlich hat dann irgendwie an einem unternehmen liegen
sondern eigentlich will man da natürlich schon irgendwie so eine form von ja rechtsstaatlichkeit oder sonstigen haben ich find's halt sehr.
Sehr schwierig weil natürlich das problem nicht weggeht ne also dadurch dass man das jetzt,
nicht mehr online ist
geht nicht das problem weg das irgendwo irgendwelche rassisten sich mit bullshit aus dem internet radikalisieren wir diskutieren ja hier genauso
dass die dass die dass wir dämliche inhalte auf youtube finden die also auch wirklich von haarsträubend da,
träume geringen ausmaß an verwurzelt in der realität gekennzeichnet sind und deswegen ist es,
tja das kann eigentlich nie eine,
dauerhafte lösung sein solche solche seiten irgendwie abzuschalten es ist aber mittelfristig immer mal was ganz schön,
aber diese spinner werden sich natürlich jetzt sofort irgendetwas anderes suchen und da irgendwie weitermachen ne also es ist eine symptom behandlung.
Und nicht eine nicht eine ursächlichen behandlung.
Vor allem auch keine keine lösung ich meine letztlich denk ich so eine lösung kann mittelfristig langfristig nur sein dass wir in irgendeiner form auf diesen planeten
zu so einem random auf anders standing kommen oder vielleicht auch noch etwas weiter führen das auf un-ebene ja das einfach die art und weise wie wir mit dem internet umgeht in irgendeiner form so auf,
internationaler vertrags basis mal festgelegt wird so wie viele dinge heute auch geächtet sind das,
man das eben auch fast nur ich glaube heute ist noch niemand in der lage also wer das ist politisch durchsetzbar noch.
Könnte man jetzt auch nur klar formulieren wieder in diese regeln eigentlich genau sein sollen ich denke wir werden noch einige jahre vielleicht,
vielleicht auch jahrzehnte.
Mit einem sich immer weiter expandieren finden und noch weiteren wilde schlenker nebenden internet abfinden müssen.
Bis das ganze mal so eine so ein zustand hat wo man sagt okay.
So wie das telefon nicht sich irgendwie konsolidiert hat und irgendwie wasserversorgung und irgendwann weiß womit was für eine art infrastruktur man sieht jetzt hier zu tun hat und wie man sie handhaben kann und sollte
und dann entsprechende kulturelle ethische regeln dafür gefunden hat dann eben dafür auch international global akzeptiert die äh wege zu.
Wie die aussehen auch keine ahnung vielleicht dauert es auch paul hat jahre werden ja noch in fünfhundert jahren gehört insofern.
Podcast wenn noch in fünfhundert jahren auf fortschein gepostet.
Ja ich hoffe zumindest also ich wäre schon froh wenn fünfhundert jahren mein kommentar forum noch läuft jetzt sagen wir die ersten fünfhundert jahren hört dann schreib doch mal wie es war was kann ich ja jetzt.
Eine sache die auch fast fünfhundert jahre uns beschäftigt hat.
Weil die auseinandersetzung zwischen moses vogel und kraftwerk,
ja auch bei lok wo die älteren hörerinnen und hörer oder euch erinnern sich wir haben das,
immer mal wieder behandelt,
neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig hat moses palm eine sequenz aus dem
kraftwerk stück metall auf metall fall verwendet und in veränderte form also als lob
in das in ein musikstück eingebunden nämlich das musikstück nur mir der rapper sabrina set look,
kennst du noch es waren alle.
Ich bin ich alt genug also.
Waren alles harte zeiten.
Da bin ich da bin ich sogar alt genug um die eigentlich schon damals gar nicht mehr richtig bekannt zu haben.
Sei froh 'n paar kelche sind auch an dir vorübergegangen,
also hat er hat auf jeden fall ein neues lied raus geschaffen so und kraftwerk insbesondere rolf wetter,
und florian schneider ess leben haben durch diese sample ihre rechte verletzt gesehen und verklagt sagten,
ja und zwar auf unterlassungserklärung schadensersatz und herausgabe der tonträger um sie dann zu vernichten das erstmal ein sympathisches anliegen ist,
die frage ist klar,
so das wäre echt super gewesen wenn das in dem moment nur seit siebenundneunzig von vornherein einfach alles nieder gebrannt worden wäre
wer jetzt auch nicht tragisch gewesen für den fortbestand der menschheit
aber es kam anders wir hatten zu dem zeitpunkt haben auch immer noch ein rechtssystem und wir sind ja hier in dem in der situation,
urheberrecht ist und da stellte sich nun die frage.
Hat kraftwerk recht das moses pelle jetzt ihr urheberrecht verletzt hat oder hat moses palm recht dass er.
So so schwierig das auch anzuerkennen ist jetzt irgendwie etwas neues geschaffen hat was darüber hinaus,
schöpfung für und wert hat und der beitrag von kraftwerk sample zu dem gesamt schaffen gering war.
Und da hat dann erst kraftwerk von bundesgerichtshof gewonnen dann wurde aber vom zweitausendsechzehn hat das bundesverfassungsgericht das urteil vom bundesgerichtshof aufgehoben und das als kunstfreiheit ein,
sehr liberale einschätzung des schaffens von moses.
Meine güte bist du bissig.
Ne du kennst das fell haben ne das ist der typ der stefan habt die nase gebrochen hat wenn ich das richtig erinnere google.
Dafür sind sie bis heute noch auf rache oder.
Das war kunstfreiheit.
Das war kunstfreiheit da hat er aber anders guck mal ich glaube man muss es stefan raab mal die nase gebrochen.
Ein lustiger typ und.
So auf den preis.
Um ein bisschen wie stefan raab zu lachen.
So und dann hat er hat es der bundes des bundesverfassungsgerichts zur teil des bgh kassiert und der bvb hat das ganze dann an den eugh hat zur einschätzung gegeben was gibt's gibt's ein bild von stefan raab mit der gebrochenen nase nenne,
die aufnahmen sind irgendwie.
Lesen wir gerade die über die umstände hat sich da irgendwie aufgeregt weil stefan raab hier so,
interviews und videoclips verrückt hat und die zuschauer aufgefordert gebastelten moses p köpfe in die sendung zu schicken zu dem titel in rab in seiner in einer sendung seiner show mit müssen.
Das hat er nicht ausgehalten der abend.
Für das gebrochene nasenbein bekam er zehntausend mark schmerzensgeld zugehört.
Tschüss.
Außerdem vierzigtausend im strafverfahren.
Ist da schon mal ganz okay so aber jetzt hat man muss es auch mal was gewonnen ganz ohne jemanden zu verprügeln.
Einfach dauerte einfach nur weil da sind das jetzt zweiundzwanzig jahre die das gedauert hat ja zweiundzwanzig jahre,
ihr seid also der bvb hat diesen fall einen olga zur einschätzung vorgelegt und der eugh hat gesagt in diesem song ist dieser song ist keine kopie denn es wurde ja nur ein fragmente aus dem kraftwerk song genommen das wurde auch verändert und da ist jetzt ein neues unabhängiges
entschieden entstanden und deswegen musste muss es padam kraftwerk auch nicht fragen ob sie das wollen.
Damit ist dieser fall nun also ein historischer eine historische rechts sager des urheberrecht findet nun also hier.
Nach zweiundzwanzig jahren ihr ende ist sommer was hashtag recht auf remix.
Du bist du singst jetzt im moses.
Hat unter anderem die firma digital protect,
gesellschaft zum schutze digitaler medien wenn ich mit denen auch mal ein bloß.
Das kann sein also muss es.
Massen abmahnung und so.
Ja ja der wusste immer wieder sein geld kriegt.
Das ist ein sympathischer mensch aber in dem fall eben ein sympathischer mensch im recht.
Enger freund von böse onkels na gut soviel dazu.
Hey siri löscht dich.
Der war ganz gut der witz.
Stellt sich raus.
Alles und weißt du was tim das wird dich jetzt bestimmt genauso schockierend wie mich das das ist alles in der cloud.
Ja und die guckt diese sirene die kann das gar nicht unbedingt die muss verbessert werden und weißt du was das muss das machen menschen die dann nämlich die schlecht gehörten.
Oder viel gehörten oder sonstigen serie aufzeichnung wenn du die zum beispiel sowas einfaches fragt wie wann spielt union und sie sagen dir wie gerade wen haben wir uns ja nochmal angezeigt.
Union philadelphia.
Union vielleicht spielt morgen um mitternacht oder sowas ja sehr gut aber halt nicht richtig also nicht nicht die richtige antwort also eine gute antwort aber nicht zu unserer frage die.
Da das findet quasi eine qualitätssicherung durch menschen statt und diese menschen die hören das was man da rein gesprochen hat.
Big news ja das wird natürlich auch erst dann von der allgemeinen verwundeten öffentlichkeit festgestellt,
wenn die wenn alle auch wirklich so ein scheiß ding im wohnzimmer stehen haben dass der okay bei siri kostet ein bisschen mehr aber bei amazon diese amazon echo dort kriegst du wenn mal wieder wenn man wieder alles raus muss für vierunddreißig euro achtzig.
Brutto stück aus plastik was erstaunlicherweise stellt sich jetzt raus gar kein hoch,
technisch vierter genialer computer ist der dich versteht,
die antworten weiß sondern einfach nur ein kleiner,
in an eine cloud schickt wo eben dann die ware funktionalität und der war die wahre intelligenz dieses gerätes sich verstecken also eigentlich ein lautsprecher oder mikrofon die fernbedienung werden.
Und,
dabei du weißt jetzt mal wieder eine news dass eine interne nicht wirklich genannte quelle dann sagte ja und total oft sind da nämlich auch,
fehler auslösung des mikrofon dabei wo wir menschen beim sex,
geschäften oder beim gespräch mit dem arzt hören,
ehrlich gesagt wenn der arzt ist so ein ding in der praxis stellt ja dann also kommt mir ein bisschen komisch vor vielleicht habe ich auch mit dem arzt telefoniert in.
Ja das ist sicherlich gemeint.
Aber musste natürlich muss natürlich irgendwie,
sex geschäft und arzt sind natürlich die sachen die uns noch irgendwie heilig sind.
Hab ich den eindruck.
Interessante zusammenstellung.
Und das wurde dann jetzt kanalisiert.
Ich weiß nicht genau ob das jetzt unbedingt also ich bin froh dass das thema dann doch nochmal entdeckt wird,
aber jetzt wo ungefähr jedes wohnzimmer mit so einem ding versehen ist ist es natürlich auch irgendwie ein bisschen,
schwierig und ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt den eindruck dass das wieder ein bisschen an der diskussion vorbeigeht das entscheidende oder am thema vorbeigeht das entscheidende ist dass alle die ganze zeit in diese,
boxen sprechen und alle stimmen alle sprache da offenbar korrekt erkannt wird oder fünfundneunzig prozent und,
dass das dann dort auch in einer sehr viel günstigeren daten in einem sehr viel günstigeren daten format vorliegt
die das was man da rein gesprochen hat nämlich nicht mehr eine audiodatei sondern eine analyse dessen was da tatsächlich gesagt wurde wofür man sich interessiert hat,
und wer eben seinen tag lang die ganze zeit mit der kiste redet.
Füttert deine ganze menge daten rein ein winziger teil dieser daten es kann nur ein winziger teil dieser daten sein,
geht dann eben als audio aufzeichnung an menschen,
die in der verarbeitung dieses audios sehr viel schlechter sind als kommt oder sehr viel langsamer sind als computer aber unter umständen sehr viel gründlicher und.
Nun wird es wird es zum thema na ja ich bin.
Ich bin da ein bisschen resigniert aber man steht da steht halt nicht auf der box drauf dass das ding funktioniert über internet oder so.
Ja also es ist jetzt bei amazon wenig überraschend bei apple ist es eigentlich,
das größere drama,
weil sie ja nun explizit mit einem anderen p die öffentlichkeit gehen und relativ viel aufwand treiben um ja tatsächlich ein großteil des prozesses oder die wesentlichen teil des prozess jungs,
und die weiß machen das ist ja das was ihre technologie von den anderen anbietern primär,
unterscheidet und halt über so verschiedene methoden wie differenzial preis etcetera versucht
war sie alles das was an informationen theoretisch über einen anschluss generiert werden könnte soweit zu verschleiern dass man es eben nicht auf personen oder,
die weiß es in dem moment zurückführen kann.
Nur besteht eben genau dieses problem was gesagt hast wie will man denn sozusagen,
in einem gerät das verstehen beibringen,
wenn man nicht irgendwann auch mal trainiert man am ende sind das ja nichts anderes als kleiner machine learning exekutive das also
gelernte methodik werden per software-update dort in diese geräte reingebracht oder was sagt
versuchen die halt mit diesen ganzen machine learning sprach verstehen,
algorithmen eben erstmal zu extrem was was was wurde gesagt,
daraus dann eben auch noch eine form weiter reduzierte konkrete abfrage des gesamt wissens in der cloud zur.
Und dabei sollte eben genau das nicht passieren dass quasi original audio rausgeschickt wird,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie ich das bei amazon in letzter zeit entwickelt hat ob sie das mittlerweile auch reduziert haben aber da lief definitiv am anfang so dass mehr oder weniger die gesprochene worte einfach in der cloud bearbeitet wurden und dann kam halt die antwort.
Ja und da haben wir auch diese wunderschöne dieses wunderschöne beispiel gehabt wo jemand eine dsgvo anfrage gestellt hat und auch diese aufzeichnung mitbekommen hat interessanterweise aber von jemand anderem.
Auch das natürlich gehört zu deinem fred model,
wenn du dich ein ding ins zimmer stellst also es ist ja es ist dramatisch.
Eigentlich dass wir diese das dass es möglich ist diese dinge an so viele menschen zu verkaufen die sich über diese technischen zusammenhänge nich im klaren sind und,
das ist eigentlich alles was ich dazu sagen würde wo ich eigentlich finde es müsste in solchen fällen irgendwie,
eben dieses in formt content ding irgendwie stattfinden so ne dass den leuten eben,
da eben nicht steht ja egal du kannst dir eine kiste kaufen die antworte dir sondern dass eben zumindest erklärt wird wie dieses gerät funktioniert.
Das wäre schon wer schon ganz angemessen gewesen apple könnte natürlich auch einfach oder die unternehmen können natürlich auch einfach ein ob dort anbieten.
Was haben sie jetzt auch angekündigt dass sie das tun wollen das eigentliche problem ist dass sie das nicht von vornherein gemacht haben weil die einzige möglichkeit quasi das zu verhindern derzeit war
siri funktionalität grundsätzlich abzuschalten was natürlich am telefon zwar möglich ist.
Allerdings verzichtest du im zweifelsfall auch auf bestimmte features also nicht nur siri selber sondern sowas wie carplay zum beispiel wenn du dein telefon,
in deinem auto mit so einem auto display verbindest wurde ja dann nochmal so ein green bekommst du auf dem sich dann apps auch nochmal speziell präsentieren können,
dann ist quasi das einschalten von siri pflicht.
Weil sie sagen du bist im auto das muss sein handy ist bei uns siri also musste serie einschalten das ist schon mal so ein hammer.
Und.
Hohen pott macht halt sagen als produkt überhaupt gar keinen sinn ohne diese funktionalität es.
Deswegen koffer der noch nicht.
Ne aber es gibt halt überhaupt gar keine andere möglichkeit mit diesem teil zu interagieren also ist das.
Ja deswegen kauft man ja auch nicht.
Ja ich habe einen gekauft so.
Du kannst ja nicht ein bluetooth keyboard dran machen oder so.
Naja.
Hey.
Na du kannst dich da ja als vertragspartner einschreiben lassen dann muss ich dir nicht immer so lange nachrichten schreiben.
Wie du scheiße wie lange nachrichten wo.
Nicht mehr ich schicke dir das alles über serie.
Die diktatur funktioniert benutze ich auch nicht weil die geht wenigstens nicht von alleine an.
Ja und ihr findet mittlerweile auch komplett auf dem diverse.
Echt kein vorstellen.
Auf dem weg auf jeden fall ist eine option zum anklicken.
Also aufm weg nutz ich die nicht dass eine tastatur dran.
Hörst du nicht.
Nee am baum hier am handy manchmal.
Vom handy da bin ich mit grade nicht so ganz sicher auf jeden stand meines steht entweder unmittelbar bevor oder war jetzt gerade so.
Aber ich ich für die tiere nur nachrichten von denen ich weiß dass in selbst bei veröffentlichungen nicht mehr gegen mich verwendet werden können sowas wie ich bin gleich da.
Ich habe die dreihundert euro dabei.
Verstehst du meine frage nicht.
Was willst du von mir löscht dich.
Arschloch.
Standardsituation der kommunikation halt.
Es gab eine fehlermeldung im internet.
Ja mal wieder das ist.
Ist ja schockierend.
Zum zum wiederholten male weil.
Ich also das ist jetzt in kürzer kurzer zeit mehrmals aufgetaucht desto auf twitter kriege ich öfter mal empfehlung von so themen empfehlen wo leute dabei hast du das schon gesehen wichtig für das nächste thema für die nächste sendung und,
irgendwie ist das immer so wenn das von fox ist dann passieren zwei sachen erstens ist die meldungen völlig auto reges,
und niemand anderes hat sie und ich bin dann irgendwie so okay ja und diesmal.
Gestaltet sich die ist es wieder so eine geschichte fortschritt also moment ich muss hier erstmal diese ganzen konzentrate king oder so ich stehe jetzt hier nichts auf der seite.
Die ist,
dad auf facebook also die die die debatte über verschlüsselung ist vorbei sie starb in den händen von facebook und er wird jetzt darüber geschrieben facebook habe,
oder whatsapp das ja facebook gehört beabsichtige.
Kleinen zeit sky and filtern zu machen also die kommunikation.
Deines whatsapp kleines findet ende zu ende verschlüsselt statt aber die whatsapp app selber.
Analysiert das was du schreibst,
und guckt moment mal hier bombe oder so wollen wir aber nicht dass da machen wir jetzt mal irgendwie dran und versuchen durch
versuchen zum beispiel hier irgendwelche wie auch immer geachteten können natürlich vollständiger oder auch nur auf höherer ebene,
zusammengefasste informationen über die kommunikation zu bekommen um beispielsweise ja
diese kommunikation abzuhören oder aber auch zum beispiel irgendwie sieht einzuordnen zu sperren oder sonstiges zu sagen so diese nachricht leitest du jetzt nicht weiter weil es handelt sich um eine fake news hat donald trump entschieden oder so ne,
also jegliche form von von analyse würde hier stattfinden und,
das wäre natürlich ein totaler ein frontalangriff auf die verschlüsselung,
das was hier fonds geschrieben hat,
ist jetzt wäre inhaltlich und in der bewertung nicht falsch aber es nun mal einfach,
nicht eine tatsache dass whatsapp das tatsächlich beabsichtigen würde so dann eben auch wann sie eben kurz darauf gezwungen.
Naja ihren artikel damit zu ergänzen dass whatsapp eben sagt dass das nicht stimmt was sie behaupten und
ja somit haben wir jetzt einen einen erfolgreichen schönen test ballon gehabt weil das wir diese debatte mal führen werden halte ich für mich so unwahrscheinlich es ist nur immer für die debatte sehr ungünstig wenn sie dadurch entschärft werden konnten kann dass eben die behauptung,
als unwahrheit,
sich herausstellt nichtsdestotrotz denke ich es ist wichtig sich darüber gedanken zu machen weil die bestrebungen solches kleinen zeit filtern gaming analysis und sowas zu haben die wird es geben die werden.
Und auf eine gewisse weise mit sehr strenger.
Mit sehr streng im maß tut facebook das ja schon weil sie jetzt irgendwie dieses massen versenden von nachrichten
einschränken und so nachdem es in indien diese vorfälle gab von lynch situationen gegen,
gegen einzelne menschen die dann sich irgendwie über als whatsapp ketten briefe,
verbreitet hatten also das thema wird uns weiterhin begleiten nur vielleicht besser nicht mit fonds weil die irgendwie ehrlich gesagt in diesem in diesem themenbereich in der nähe immer so ein bisschen schlecht sind.
Dann gibt es eine schöne recherche von netz politik org die ehrlich gesagt in der form schon immer wieder
stattgefunden hat und auch immer wieder teilweise veröffentlicht wurde ich kann zumindest sagen das ist jetzt für mich als jemand der all all das liest und verfolgt nicht so.
Viel neues gab außer dass sie jetzt auf frag den staat sich ein kaufvertrag für das,
produkt finns bei aus dem hause gamma fischer organisiert.
Wo es nämlich darum ging die ganze debatte ging ja über staatstheater ging ja eigentlich los mit dem damaligen bbk gesetz und einem
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichtes indem das neue grundrecht auf die,
vertraulichkeit und integrität informationsveranstaltung systeme uns,
zu gebilligt wurde und wie das so ist mit grundrechten danach geht es dann eben darum die einzuschränken,
es kam diese ganze thematik online durchsuchung es kann die ganze thematik
quellen und ein all diesen in einer situation in der eigentlich relativ klar war dass das nicht geht,
dass ein staatsstraße einer sehr enge grenzen erfüllen muss und dass das produkt finde bei aus dem hause gamma finn fischer das nicht tut hat berlin.
Diesen staatsferne eben dennoch gekauft,
für ein paar hunderttausend euro und ähm da findet ist dann auch für vom bundesrechnungshof dafür gerückt worden
und weil es eben klar war dass sie das das geld werden sie nicht einsetzen können weil es eben rechtswidrig wäre diese software zu dem einsatz,
zu bringen für den sie gedacht ist,
jedenfalls andre und netzwerk verfolgen dieses thema sehr viel länger und sehr viel ausführlicher als es jetzt diese neue veröffentlichte oder neue vertrag den startete vertrag.
Hergibt und das ist auch in diesem artikel so zusammengefasst deswegen ist das von mir eine wärmste leser empfehlung die wir jetzt hier nicht nochmal in der sendung zusammenfassen sondern sagen geht bitte zu unseren freunden,
klickt auf den link in den shownotes und besucht.
Schaut euch an was da so über eben ein sehr langen zeitraum mal nochmal minutes zusammengeschrieben wurde wieder auch jeweils die rechtliche situation ist denn gerade im bereich staatstheater
das sage ich als jemand der den derzeit verfolgt im podcast verfolgt der auch schon sachverständiger zwischen herz im bundestag war das ist
tatsächlich auch eine sage
und da da eben auch andere personen als musik drin beteiligt sind ist es ein bisschen,
komplizierter und deswegen wäre es der empfehlung
das mal zu lesen könnte er bei netz politik ist ja alles frei verfügbar genauso wie übrigens bei der eu kommen.
Ja da wurde eigentlich schon länger dran gearbeitet es gab wohl zweitausendelf da schon mal einen ersten vorstoß der die von der eu-kommission veröffentlichen dokumente möglichst frei
zugänglich machen soll jetzt ist allerdings ein weiterer interessanter.
Unternommen worden denn seit einiger zeit sind von der kommission veröffentlichte texte also ich denke mal das bezieht sich im wesentlichen halt auf,
pressemitteilung und was du sonst aber halt gegebenenfalls ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau ob alles ist so aber das ist so das ziel.
Geht es auch für videos von günther oettinger wenn ihr englisch spricht.
Ich frage mich was jetzt genau darunter fällt also zum beispiel aus dem bildmaterial statistiken diagramm lief es gibt ja auch diverse druck produktion also ich gehe mal davon aus dass es dass es im wesentlichen alles,
betrifft und all diese ganzen inhalte sollen künftig,
oder werden jetzt schon seit einiger zeit unter einer creative comments der neuesten version
vier null in der bei variante veröffentlicht werden das heißt wesentlichen musst du nur sagen ist von der europäischen kommission und das war's und dann kannst du dieses,
das weiter verwenden es wird auch noch explizit unterstützt dass diese ganzen lizenz texte,
in sprachen übersetzt werden wo das offensichtlich noch nicht geschehen ist und für metadaten,
rohdaten und wie es so schön heißt andere dokumente von vergleichbarer natur gibt's dann noch einen weiteren schritt und dann wird das ganze unter die c null also die c c c public,
null und ist jetzt die null das.
Das publikum zu null ist das ist es ist.
Ja ist genau das ist jetzt genau es ist die null also die party sprich nimm mach,
und so egal gerade bei daten extrem wichtig und richtig auch das heißt man bekommt,
datenmaterial künftig vielleicht hoffentlich statistiken analysen auswertung untersuchungen studien alles dieses,
zumindest problemlos zu veröffentlichen und vor allem im falle von daten,
wunderbar weiter zuvor bearbeiten ohne gleichen und eine zentrale zu treten könnte sich die bundesregierung auch mal zu legen.
Wieso witzig was machen sie denn dass sie da das sie da überhaupt irgendwie eine lizenz oder ein urheberrecht dran beanspruchen das ist doch schon bezahlt also dass ich diese diskussion überhaupt stellt verstehe ich nicht so.
Urheberrecht kannst du ja,
du wirst du ja gar nicht los in dem moment wo du etwas schaffst ist es ja bei design automatisch urheberrechte geschützt dem kannst du dich gar nicht entziehen,
deswegen ist ja die explizite benennung einer lizenz die eben dann diese nutzung ermöglicht so wichtig man könnte natürlich auch mal das urheberrecht umdrehen fordern wir ja schon lange dass man sagt alles was euer rechtlich geschützt ist,
muss auch als solches erstmal registriert.
Steht auf jeden fall jetzt unter freien lizenz und wir können wir sind gespannt was muss es per damit macht.
Ganz ohne einmal auf die fresse.
So du kriegst du kriegst noch richtig richtig auf der nase heute.
Ich bin ja auch nur endlich mal vom stress so.
Ja ja.
Friends reminder.
Ähm wir haben es hier schon mal angesagt dass einen neuen single,
sucht die deadline
ist der fünfzehnte september zwanzig neunzehn das ist kurz nach dem camp da jetzt mit dem camp beschäftigt seit sollte es jetzt tun es geht um eine vollzeitstelle in brüssel dauerhafte anstellung mit,
competitive celery also mit markt üblicher,
entlohnung marktüblichen lohn soll muss so schnell wie möglich gefüllt werden diese position.
Spätestens der beginn wäre fünfzehnter oktober zwanzig neunzehn je früher desto besser da ist es also jetzt dringend die deadline für bewerbung wurde er länger verlängert und wer sich dort,
angesprochen gesprochen führt ist,
herzlich gebeten sich doch hier mal zu überlegen ich denke das ist eine natürlich schon eine eine stelle von,
hoho,
prestige und hohe anforderungen verantwortlichkeit aber das ist genau deshalb brauchen wir auch,
die besten der besten und die besten der besten hören natürlich logbuch.
So sieht's aus.
Ja und die beste also wir haben wirklich sehr gute leute bei glaube ich leider gehen die da jetzt weg machen wir gehen jetzt woanders hin das neue nachkommen ne wir brauchen neue beste.
Damit sind wir am ende der sendung ich denke dass wir tatsächlich die letzte sein vom camp.
Das.
Einfach damit wir wieder themen haben fürs camp.
Und wenn du nicht noch was sagen willst danke ich jetzt.
Ich danke ganz besonders unsere lieben kathrin jetzt auch.
Ganz herzlich gedankt und gegrüßt und so weiter außerdem.
Ebenso herzlich und freundlich danke ich dem norbert.
Ich denke es nicht alle nicht ne weil sie vielleicht kennst du die.
Doch kannst du sein.
Und ich danke tobias michael hanno frank,
markus für besondere und oder fortwährend unterstützung.
Jut,
ich danke dir minus das für diese sendung jetzt dann doch noch.
Ach das ist doch nicht das wäre doch nicht nötig wäre doch nicht nötig das ist ja dann doch mal bei der trauung zehnten sendung.
Bitte bitte gerne.
Ach die tränen schön.
Ja ich bin.
Glücklich dass wir das jetzt zu ende geführt haben denn der nächste termin liegt schon vor der tür euch einen schönen rest kann man das so sagen.
August echt,
ja nein nein da kommen keine ahnung also auf jeden fall auf dem camp und danach geht's auch irgendwie weiter mal gucken wie dann das camp so,
nach nach wirkt so aller aller aller spätestens im september sind wir dann wieder voll im saft und dann gibt's hier logbuch bis zum abwinken also bis bald tschüss.